okay so hi everyone so
today's to continue talking about search
so so that's what we were going to start
doing finish off some of this stuff
we've started talking about last time
and then after that switch to some of
the more interesting topics like
learning so a few announcements so the
solutions to the old exams are online
now so if you guys want to start
studying for the exam you can do that so
so start looking at some of those
problems I think that would be useful
actually let me start with the search to
lecture because I think that might be
like that has a review of some of the
topics we've talked about so it might be
easier to do that also I'm not connected
to the network so we're not going to do
the questions or show the videos because
I have I have a hard time connecting a
network in this room ok all right so so
let's start continue talking about
search so if you guys remember we had
this the city block problem so let's go
back to that problem and let's just try
to do a review of some of the some of
the search search algorithms we talked
about last time so so suppose you want
to travel from city 1 to city n only
going forward and then from city n you
want to go backwards so and back to city
1 going only backwards okay so you so
the problem statement is kind of like
this you're starting in city 1 you're
going you're going forward and you're
getting to some city n so maybe you were
doing out on this and then after that
you want to go backwards and get to get
to city one again so you're going to
some of these cities so that's the goal
and then the cost of going from any city
I to city J is equal to CIJ ok so so
that sells so the question is what which
one of these following algorithms could
you use to solve this problem and it
could be multiple of them so we have
depth first search breadth first search
dynamic programming and uniform cost
search and these were the algorithms we
talked about last time
so maybe just talk to your neighbors for
a minute
and then we can do votes on each one of
these yes
listen pasa pasa okay let me take that
again thank you thank you for so let's
maybe start talking about this so how
about depth-first search like how many
will saying we can use their search how
many people think we can't use that
search it's very like good split so so
some of the people think we can't use
that their search what are some reasons
maybe yeah so here we are basically
going from city one to see the end each
one of these edges have a cost of CIJ
I'm just saying CIJ is greater than or
equal to zero that's the only thing I'm
saying about CIJ but if remember that
first search you really wanted the cost
to just be equal to zero because if you
remember that whole tree like the whole
point of depth-first search was I could
just stop whenever I could find a
solution and we were assuming that the
cost of all the edges is just equal to
zero so so we can't really use that
search here because because our cost is
not zero so assuming that like not again
you know that reasoning how about
breadth-first search can be used for
search
so so that's a good way so what
suggesting is can we think about the
problem as going from city one to city
in and then after that like introduce
like a whole new problem that continues
that and starts from CDN and goes to
city one let me get back to that points
like in a second because like you could
potentially think about that actually
like that might be an interesting way of
thinking about it but but irrespective
of that I can't use depth or search so
I'm so far I'm just talking about depth
or search irrespective of how I'm
looking at the problem the costs are
going to be nonzero so because the costs
are going to be nonzero I can't use that
first search so so let's talk about
matters so how about birth research can
I use breadth-first search you cannot
use fresh first search here because for
breadth-first search if you remember you
really wanted all the costs to be the
same they didn't need to be 0 date but
they needed to be the same thing because
then you could just go over the levels
and then here I'm not like I'm not
saying I'm not putting any restrictions
on CIJ being the same thing ok so now
let's talk about dynamic programming how
about dynamic programming can be used
sine amock programming alright so that
looks right right like we could use
dynamic programming here everything
looks ok CI J's are positive looks fine
how about actually one question so so
don't I have cycles here we kind of
briefly talked about this already
so don't I have like this cycle here so
we could actually use dynamic
programming here even if it kind of
looks like we have a cycle and the
reasons we can kind of use this trick
for we can basically draw this out again
and for going forward basically go all
the way here and then after that we're
going backwards kind of include the
directionality too so all I am doing is
I'm extending the state this
space to not just be the city but be the
city in addition to that be the
direction that we're going so if I'm in
city four here it's City for going
forward and if at some point in the
future I'm in city and on a four again
it's City four going backwards so I'll
keep track of both the city and the
directionality and when I do that then
I'm kind of breaking the cycle like I'm
not putting any cycles here and I can
actually use dynamic programming that
makes it and then uniform cost search
that dad also sounds good - right like
uniform cost search you could actually
use that doesn't matter if you have
cycles or not and then we have positive
positive non negative costs so we could
use uniform cost search yeah all right
so this was just a quick review of some
of the things we talked about last time
and another thing we talked about last
time was this notion of state okay so so
we started talking about three search
algorithms and at some point we switch
to dynamic programming and uniform cost
search where we are where we don't need
to like we don't need to have this
exponential blow-up and the reason
behind that was you're we have
memoization and in addition to that we
have this notion of state okay and so
what is a state a state is a summary of
all past actions that are sufficient for
us to choose the future optimally so so
we need to be really careful about
choosing our state so in this previous
question we looked at past actions so if
you look at like all cities that you go
over it can be in City one then three
and four five six and I see a three
again so in terms of state the things
that you want to keep track of is what
city you are in but in addition to that
you want to have the directionality
because you need to know like where you
are and how you're getting back okay so
and we did a couple of examples around
that trying to figure out what is what
is like a specific notion of state for
various problems all right so so we
started last time talking about search
problems and and we sort of formalizing
it so if you remember our paradigm of
modeling and inference and learning we
started kind of modeling search problems
using this formalism where we defined a
starting state that's a start and then
we talked about the actions of
which is a function over States which
returns all possible actions and then we
talked about the cost function so the
cost function can take a state an action
and tell us what is the cost of that
that that that edge and then we talked
about the successor function which takes
the state in action and tells us where
we end up at and at the end we had this
is end function that was just checking
if you're in an end state or not so
these were all the things that we needed
to define a search problem and we kind
of tried that in a couple of examples to
trim' example the city example of that
and then after talking about these these
different ways of thinking about search
problems we started talking about
various types of inference algorithm so
we talked about tree search so depth
first search breadth first search depth
research with iterative deepening
backtracking search and then after that
we talked about some of these graph
search type algorithms like uniform cost
search and and dynamic programming so
last time we did an example of uniform
cost search but we didn't get to prove
the correctness of it so I want to
switch to some of the last last last
times slides to just go over this quick
theorem and then after that just switch
back to to this lecture ok so uniform
cost search like if you remember what we
were doing in uniform cost search we had
three different sets
we had an export set which was basically
the set of states that we have visited
and we are sure how to get to them and
we know the optimal path and we know
everything about them we had this
frontier set which was a set with a set
of states that we have got to them but
we are not sure if the cost that we have
is the best cost cost there might be a
better way of getting to them and we
don't know like we are not sure yet and
then we have the uh neck Sports set of
states which are basically states that
we haven't seen yet so we did this
example where we started with all the
states in the unexplored set and then we
moved them to the frontier and then from
the frontier we moved them to the export
set so so this was the example that we
did under board okay and then we
realized that like even if you have
cyclones we can actually do this
algorithm and then
we ended up finding the best path being
from A to B to C to D and that cost
three
so let's actually implement uniform cost
search and so I think we didn't do this
last time so going back to our set of so
we started writing up these algorithms
for search problems so we have we have
written dynamic programming already and
backtracking search so now we can we can
try to kind of implement uniform cost
search and for doing so we need to have
this priority queue data structure so
this is in a util file I'm just showing
you what it like what functions it has
it has an update function and it has a
remove min function so it's just a data
structure that I'm gonna use for my
frontier
because like my frontier I'm popping off
things off my frontier so I'm going to
use this data structure alright so let's
go back to uniform cost search so we're
going to define this frontier where
you're adding states to it from
unexplored set we're adding states to
the frontier okay and it's going to be a
priority queue so so we have that data
structure because we just imported util
and you're going to basically add this
start state with a cost of 0 to the
frontier so that's the first thing we do
and then after that like while the
frontier is not empty so while true what
we were going to do is we're going to
remove the minimum past cough an element
from the frontier so so basically just
pop off the frontier the best thing that
exists there and just move that to the
explored set okay so when I pop off the
thing from the frontier basically I get
this past cost and I get the state ok
all right so so if we are in an end
state then you're just going to return
that pass cost with the history I'm not
putting the history here for now I'm
just returning the cost okay so after
popping off a state from the frontier
the thing we were doing was we were
adding the children of that so the way
we do that is we're going to use this
successor and cost function that we
defined last time so we can basically
iterate over action new state and costs
in the successor and cost function and
basically update our frontier by adding
these new States to it ok and then the
cost that you're going to
it's cost post past cost if that is
better so so that's what the update
function of the frontier does and that's
pretty much it like that is uniform cost
search you add stuff to the frontier you
pop up stuff from the frontier and and
that way you explore them you move
things from now on exports it to the
export set so let's just try that out it
looks like it is doing the right thing
so it got the same value as dynamic
programming so looks like it kind of
works okay so this code is also online
so if you want to take a look at it
later actually this is not what I want
to do yeah okay all right so so that was
and and here's also the pseudo code of
uniform cost search okay okay so we have
between there's a question right so what
sort of the question is what's the
runtime of uniform cost search so the
wrong time of uniform cost search is
order of n log n where the log n is
because of like the bookkeeping of the
priority queue and you're going over all
the edges so so he can think of n here
as the edges and worst case scenario if
you have a fully connected graph it's
technically and squirt log n but in
practice we have sparse or graph so
people usually refer to B that's just n
log n where n is the number of states
that you have explored and it's actually
not all of the states it's the states
that you have explored okay and dynamic
programming is order of n so technically
like dynamic programming is slightly
better but really events actually go
first give it is the only difference
between this and I stress that you just
don't have them all
yeah so what's the questions was the
difference between this and the
Dijkstra's algorithm they're very
similar the only difference is this is
trying to solve a search problem so
you're not I like exploring all the
states when you get to the solution you
get to the solution and then you just
return that Dijkstra you're going from
you're basically exploring all of all of
the states in there in your graph all
right sounds good okay so I just want to
quickly talk about this correctness
theorem so so for uniform cost search we
actually have a correctness theorem
which basically says uniform cost search
does the right thing so what basically
the theorem says is if we have a state
that we are popping off the frontier and
we're moving it from the frontier to the
export then it's priority value which is
equal to past cost of s is actually the
minimum cost of getting to to the state
s so what this is saying is let's say
that this is my export set so this is my
exports and then right here is my
frontier and I have a start state okay
and then I have some state s that right
now I've decided that I am popping off s
from the frontier to export because that
is the best thing that has the best pass
cost so what the theorem says is this
this path that I have from and start to
s is the shortest path possible to get
to get to the state s ok so the way to
prove that is to show that the cost of
this path is lower than any other path
paths that go from s start to s so let's
say there is some other path this green
one that goes from s star to s some
other way and the way that it goes to s
is it should probably leave the export
set of states from some state called t
maybe to some ghost go to some other
state nu and then from you go to us UN s
can be the same thing but the point of
it is if I have this other path that
goes through s it needs to leave the
export set from some state so what I
want to show is I want to show that the
cost of
the green line I want to show that that
is greater than the cost of the black
line okay all right so the cost of the
Green Line what is the cost of the Green
Line it's going to be the cost to here
and then cost of T to you and the cost
of u to s so I can say well this cost is
actually greater than or equal to
priority of T because that is the cost
of getting to T plus cost of C to you
and I'm just dropping that's this last
part the u to s I'm just dropping that
okay so cost of green is like at least
equal to priority of t plus cost of T TT
to you okay well what is that equal to
priority is just a number right it's
just a number that you're getting off
the priority queue so that is actually
equal to past cost of t plus cost of t
to you and and this value is going to
actually be greater than or equal to
priority do you well why is that because
if you is in my frontier I visited you
so I already have some priority value
for you and the value that I've assigned
for the priority of you is either equal
to this path cost of T plus cos of T to
you because I've like seen that to use
in my export use in my frontier so I've
definitely seen this or it is something
better that I don't know what it is
right so so priority of U is going to be
less than or equal to this path cost of
T plus cost of T to you okay and well
what do I know in terms of priority of
you and priority of s well I know
priority of U is going to be greater
than or equal to priority of this well
why is that because I already know I'm
popping off s next
I'm not topping off you like like I I
know I'm popping off the the thing that
has the least amount of priority and the
least value here and that's s and and
well that is equal to cost of the black
line
right so that was just a quick like
proof of why uniform cost search always
returns kind of the best minimum cost
path all right so let's go to the slides
again so just the comparison quick
comparison between dynamic programming
of uniform cost search so we talked
about dynamic programming we know it
doesn't allow cycles but in terms of
action cost it can be anything like it
look you can have negative cost you can
have positive cost and in terms of
complexity is order N and then uniform
cost search you can have cycles so that
is cool but the problem is the costs
need to be non-negative and it's order n
log N and if you have if you end up in a
situation where you have cycles and your
costs are actually negative there's this
other algorithm called bellman-ford that
we are not talking about in this class
but you could actually like have a
different algorithm that addresses those
sort of the settings okay all right okay
so that was that was this idea of in
France right now we have like a good
series of ways of going about doing
inference for search problems you have
formalize them and now the plan for this
lecture is is to think about learning so
how are we going to go about learning
when we have search problems and when
our search problem is not fully
specified and there are things in the
search problem that are not specified
and you want to learn what they are like
the cost okay so so that's going to be
the first part of the lecture and then
towards the end of the lecture we are
going to talk about a few other
algorithms that make things faster so so
smarter ways of making things faster
we're going to talk about a star and
some sort of relaxation type strategies
all right so so let's go back to our
transportation problem so so this was
our transportation problem where we had
a start state and we can either walk and
by walking we can go from state s to
state s plus 1 and that costs 1 or we
can take a tram a magic tram that takes
us from state s to state to s and that
costs - ok
want to get to state so we can formalize
that a search problem we can like we saw
it we saw this last time we can actually
try to find what is the best path to get
from state 1 to any state and like we
saw like past like walk walk tram tram
tram walked round tram this is one
potential like optimal task that one can
get ok but the thing is the world is not
perfect right like modeling is actually
really hard like it's not that we always
have this nice model with everything and
we could end up in scenarios where we
have a search problem and we don't
actually know what the costs are our
actions are so we don't actually know
what the cost of walking is or what the
cost of traumas but maybe we actually
have access to to this optimal path like
maybe I know the optimal path is walk
walk tram tram tram walk tram tram but I
don't know what the costs are so the
point of learning is is to go about
learning what these cost values are
based on these these optimal paths that
be half so so I want to actually learn
the cost of walking is one and the cost
of travesty and this is actually a
common problem that we have like in
machine learning in general so like for
example you might have data from how a
person does something or like how a
person let's say like grasp an object
and and I have no idea what was the cost
that the person was optimizing to grasp
an object right but I have like the
trajectory I know like what the path
they took when they picked up an object
so what I can do is if I have access to
that path of how they picked up an
object then from that I can actually
learn what was the cost function that
they were optimizing because then I can
put that cost function maybe on a on a
robot that does the same thing
that's a good question so the question
is is it possible to have multiple
solutions yes so we are gonna actually
see that like later like what sort of
like solutions are we going to get or
they're there there could be cases where
we have multiple solutions the ratio of
it is the thing that matters so if you
have like walk is one tram is for if you
get to an eight you kind of get the same
sort of behavior and then it also
depends on what sort of data you have
like if your data allowed you to
actually recover that that's true
solution so so we're gonna actually talk
about all this cases okay all right okay
so if you think about it when the search
problem we were trying to solve this was
the inference problem was when we were
given kind of a search formulation and
we are given a cost and our goal was to
find a sequence of actions this optimal
sequence of actions that was the
shortest path or the best path and and
some thought some way and this is a
forwards problem so search is this
forward problem where you're given a
cost and you want to find the sequence
of actions okay so it's interesting
because learning in some sense is an
inverse problem it's the inverse of
search so the inverse of search is if
you give me that sequence of actions
that's the best sequence of actions that
you've got then can you figure out what
the cost this so so in some sense you
can think of learning as this inverse
problem of search N and we are going to
kind of address that so I'm going to go
over one example to talk about learning
and I'm actually going to use the
notation of the machine learning
lectures that we had at the beginning of
like last week basically so let's say
that we have maybe I can draw this so
let's say that we have a search problem
without costs and that's our input so if
so so we are kind of framing this
problem of learning as a prediction
problem and if you remember prediction
problems and prediction problems we had
an input so our input was X okay and in
this case you're saying our input is a
search problem search problem
without costs okay so that is my input
and then we have outputs and in this
case my my output Y is this optimal
sequence of actions that one could get
yet so it's a solution path so it's a
solution and what I want to do is I want
to look like if you remember machine
learning the idea was I would want to
find this predictor this F function f
that would take an input f of X and then
it would basically return the solution
path and in other settings that it would
generalize so so that was kind of the
idea that we explored in machine
learning and you kind of want to do the
same thing in here so let's start with
I'm gonna draw that here so let's start
with an example where we are in city one
and then maybe we walk to City 2 so we
can walk to city 2 and then from there
maybe I have two options I can keep
walking to get to City four so I can do
walk walk walk
or maybe I can take the tram and end up
in City four and and the thing is I
don't actually know what the costs of
these these actions are I don't know
what the cost of don't walk is what the
cost of tram is but one thing I know is
that my my solution path my Y is equal
to walk walk walk so so one way to go
about this is to actually start with
some initialization of these costs so
the way we are defining these costs are
going to be I'm going to use the word
I'm gonna write here maybe oh just right
up here I'm going to use W like because
I want to use the same notation as the
learning lectures so W is going to be
the weight that each one of my actions I
have two actions in this case I can
either walk or I can take the tram so
I'm going to call them action one so W
of action one is W of walking and then W
of action
is w of taking the tram so action to is
taking the track so I'm defining these W
values and the way I'm defining these
weights is just as a function of actions
this could technically be a function of
state and actions but right now I'm just
simplifying this and I'm saying the W's
is this values the cost of walking just
depend did the cost of going from 1 to 2
it just depends on my action it doesn't
depend on what state I am in you could
imagine settings where it actually
depends on like what city you are in to
okay so so then under that scenario what
is the cost of cost of y it is going to
be double your walk plus double your
walk plus double your walk okay so what
I'm suggesting is let's just start with
something let's just start with yeah
let's just start with these weights so
I'm gonna say walking costs three and
it's always going to cost three again
the reason it's always going to cost
three is I'm basically saying my weights
only depend on the action
they don't depend on the state so it's
always going to cost three and I'm gonna
say well why not let's just say the tram
takes the cost of two okay so this
doesn't like look right but like let's
just say I assume this is the right
solution okay so now what I want to do
is I want to be able to update these
weights update these values in a way
that I can get this optimal path that I
have this this walk walk walk so how can
I do that so I started with this random
initializations of what the weights are
okay so now that I have done that I can
I can try to figure out what is the
optimal optimal path fear based on these
weights so what is my prediction so that
is y prime that is my prediction based
on these weights that I've just set up
in terms of what what the optimal path
is well what is that that is walked ran
because this cost five and discussed
nine so with these weights these random
weights or them just come up with I'm
going to pick what contra and that is my
prediction okay so now what we want to
do is you want to update our w's based
on the fact that our true label is walk
walk walk and our prediction is walking
on
and the algorithm that kind of does this
it's just like the most like silliest
thing possible so so what it does is
it's going to first look at the truth
value of W okay so it's going to look at
so so so the weights are starting from
so I decided that this guy is three and
I decided that this guy's too and I'm
gonna update them so I'm gonna look at
every action in this path and for every
action in this path I'm going to down
wait the the weight of that well why am
I going to do that because I don't want
to penalize that right this is the true
thing I want the weight of the true
thing to be small so I see walk I'm like
okay so I see you walk the weight of
that was three I'm going to down rate
that by one I'm gonna make that two I
see walk again so I'm gonna bring that
one I see walk again I'm gonna subtract
one again I end up at zero okay now I'm
going to go over my prediction and then
for every action I see here I'm going to
bring it up bring the cost the weight up
by one so I see walk again here I'm
going to bring it up by one so so these
were subtract subtract subtract bring it
up by one because it's over my Y Prime
and then I see Tran and then because I
see tram I'm going to bring this up by
one and that ends up in three so my new
weights here are going to be three the
the weight of walk just became one and
then the weight of Tran just became
three okay and and now I can kind of
repeat doing this and see if that gets
me this this optimal solution or not so
I'm gonna try running my search
algorithm if I run my search algorithm
this path and this path cost for this
path cost three so I'm actually going to
get this path and this path so my new
prediction is just going to be walk walk
walk there are going to be the same
thing my weights are now going to change
I'm going to converge
so I'm talking about a very simplified
version of this but the idea is always
one so the very simplified version of
this is this version where I'm saying
the W is just depend on on actions if
you if you make the weights depend on
state and actions there is a more
generalized form of this this is called
the strip and the structure perceptron
algorithm you'll talk about who briefly
talked about the diversion where there
is a state action too but for in this
case where it just depends on action
you're literally just bring it up by one
or play whatever like whatever you're
bringing it up here you got to bring it
down by the same thing so it's plus and
minus a what a raise so what am i doing
to minus one so I'll get to that so so
when I look at Y here right like this is
the thing that I really want it so if I
so when I see walk I realize that
walking was a good thing so I need to
bring down the weight of that but if the
weights that I already had like knew
that walking is pretty good then like
the rates that I already had knew that
walking is pretty good I should like
cancel that out so that's why we're
doing the plus one because like at this
stage like I knew walking is pretty good
up here like like my prediction also
said walk so if I'm subtracting it off
should add it to to kind of like get
them cancel that but like right here
like I didn't know walking is good so
I'm going to bring down the weight of
that and then bring up the weight of
Tran I mistakenly thought ram is the way
to go so to avoid that next time around
I'm going to make the cost of
higher so I don't take that route it
anymore there's a questionnaire secured
we like the only resource I'd like a
sentence
my primary another white pine is
different from walking yes but then like
what if like we have like a long
sequence and white time is only
differently like one small location and
like with that change awaits efficiently
yeah so if so you're asking okay so if
my yny prom prime are kind of like the
same thing walk walk walk or something
and at the very end this last one they
were going to be different yeah so like
we were just then for that last one
you're just adding one right so so it
does like waited it does actually
address that and it just run you can run
it until you get this sequences to be
exactly the same thing so you don't have
any mistakes
does it matter for our new class become
negative does it matter if our new costs
because it depends on what sort of
search algorithm you're using at the end
of the day it's fine if you're using
dynamic programming so I can have like a
negative cost here and I'm just calling
like dynamic programming at the end of
the day with that and that is fine the
other is fine if the cost becomes the
question is will be God here one and
three is this actually right like if you
remember like when we define a strand
problem we said walking costs one and
trial costs 2 but we never got that well
the reason we never got that is the
solution we are going to get here is
just based on our training data so if my
training data is just walk walk walk
this is like the best thing I can get
and I can kind of like converge to the
solution where the two end up being
equal I don't know how many mistakes on
this if I have more like data points
that I'm going to do this longer and
actually try it out another training
data and then I might converge to a
different thing so as far as
initializing the weights
I'm assuming went further away you are
from the Asheville truth the bunkers
gonna take I please okay so the question
is how do we initialize so in the
natural algorithm you're just
initializing with zero so we're
initializing everything by zero it's
actually not that bad because you just
you just basically have this sequence
and in it for the more general case
you're computing a feature value that
you just compute the full thing and you
just do one single so it is not that
costly if we have that input and
incorporate that into that so you're
saying if we have some prior knowledge
about the cost can be incorporated yeah
that is interesting so in this current
format so if you have some prior
algorithm maybe you like then that your
prediction is going to be better right
so if you have some knowledge about it
maybe you'll get a better prediction and
then based on that you don't update it
as much so maybe you can incorporate in
the search problem but like in again
this is the most like general form of
this algorithm the simple kind of with
the simplified version of it also like
even like for the action so it's not
doing anything fancy it's not doing
something that hard either
overfeeding at all yes it's going to it
can told you yeah I'll show some
examples on this like we're going to
code this up and then we'll see
overfitting kind of situations do so so
I'll get back to that actually all right
all right so all right so let's move on
okay so so this is just like the things
that are on the slides or what I've
already talked about so yeah so here is
an example so we start with three for a
walk and two for tram and then the idea
is like how are we going to change the
costs so we get the solution that we
were hoping for and and as I was saying
well we can assume that the costs only
depend on the action so I'm assuming
cost of SN a is just W of a in the most
general form it can depend on
on the state - okay so then if you take
any candidate output past then what
would be the cost of the path it would
just be the sum of these W values over
over all the edges so it would just be W
of a 1 plus W of a 2 force W of 8 a 3
and as you've seen in this example the
cost of a path is just double your work
first over your walk for some of your
walk or double your walk plus W of
so so that's all this slide is saying so
that's how we compute the cost all right
so so now let's actually look at this
algorithm like running in practice okay
let me actually go over this video code
so so we start analyzing double used to
be equal to zero and then after that
we're going to iterate for some amount
of T and then we have a training set of
examples it might not be just one here I
just showed this one example like like
the only training example I had was was
that wok wok wok is a good thing but I
can you can imagine having multiple
training examples for your search
problem and then what you can do is you
can compute your prediction so that is y
prime given that you have some W and you
can start with this W equal to zero and
then just compute your prediction Y
prime and then basically you can do this
plus and minus type of action so for
each action that is in your true Y that
is in your true label you're going to
subtract one so to decrease the cost of
true Y and then for each action that is
in your prediction you're going to add
add one to kind of increase the cost of
the predicted Y okay all right so so
let's look at implementing this one and
let's try to look at some examples here
all right so let's go back to the
problem so this is again the same trying
problem you just want to use the same
sort of format I actually went back and
wrote up the history here if you
remember last time I was saying I'm not
returning the history now we have a way
of returning history by each one of
these algorithms because we were going
to call dynamic programming and we need
the history all right so let's go back
to our transportation problems so we had
a cost of 1 and 2 for walking and tram
but what we want to do is we want to put
parameters there so we want to actually
put this weight and we can give that to
our transportation problem so
in addition to the number of bucks now
I'm going to actually give like the
weight of different actions okay all
right so then walking has a weight and
tram has weight so now I have updated my
transportation problem to generally take
different values so so now we want to be
able to generate some some training
examples so that's what I want to do I
want to generate different types of
training examples that we can call so we
can get these true labels so let's
assume that the true weights for our
training example is just one on two so
that is what we really want okay and
then you're going to just write this
prediction function that we can call up
later to get different values of Y so
the prediction function is going to get
the number of blocks so so it's going to
get an N the number of blocks here and
it is going to act with this path that
we want so it's going to act with these
Y values this different time okay so all
right so the whole point of prediction
is is basically like running this f of X
function and we can define our
transportation problem its width and
weight and the way we were going to get
this is by calling dynamic programming
so someone asked earlier could the cost
be negative well yes because now I'm
calling dynamic programming and if like
it's problem has negative cost that is
fine too so and the history is going to
get and the action new state and an cost
right so but the thing that I actually
want to return from my predict function
is a sequence of actions so I'll just
get the action out of this history that
I get from dynamic programming some
calling dynamic programming on my
problem that is going to return a
history or get the sequence of actions
from that and that is my predict
function and I can just call that later
so let's go back to generating examples
so so I'm just going to go for try out
and end to go from 1 to 10 so one block
to 10 bucks and we're calling the
predict function on these true weights
to get the true y-values so these are my
true labels okay
and those are my examples so my examples
are just calling generate examples here
okay so let's just print out our
examples see how it looks like we
haven't done anything like in terms of
like the algorithm or anything we're
just like creating these training
examples by calling this predict
function on the true weights I have a
typo here generate examples I need
parentheses I'll fix the typo okay so
that kind of looks right right so that's
my training example one through nine and
then what is what is the path that you
would want to do if you have these true
weights the one and two okay so now I
have my examples so I'm ready to write
this structured perceptron algorithm it
gets my examples it gets the training
examples which are these paths and then
we're going to iterate for some range
and then we can basically go over all
the examples that we have in our true
true y values and then we can't we can
basically go and update our weights
based on based on that and based on our
predictions so let's initialize the
weights to just be zero so that's for
walking in tram they're just zero and
prediction actions this is when we're
calling predict based on the current
weights so if my current weights are
zero then pred actions is just that y
prime so pred actions is y prime true
actions is y like the things that we had
on the slides if okay and then I want to
count the number of mistakes I'm making
too so if the two are not equal to each
other then I'm going to just keep it
counter for number of mistakes if the
two become equal then then my number of
mistakes is zero I'm going to break it
in maybe I'm happy then okay so I make a
prediction and then after that I'm going
to update the weight values
okay so how do I update
well basically subtract if you're in
true actions which is why the labels
that have created from my training
examples and then two plus one if you're
in prediction actions based on the
current weight values and then that's
pretty much it like you like that is
structured perceptron okay so let's just
print things nicely so we can print the
iteration and number of mistakes we have
and what is actually the weight values
that we have and I'm just breaking this
whenever I have like no mistakes
so if number of mistakes is zero oh I'll
just break this okay
that sounds good so if number of
mistakes is zero then I'll break okay
so all good I'm gonna run this it's not
gonna do anything because I didn't call
it so I'll go back and actually call it
I have another typo here if you guys can
guess like where does my typos
this is gonna give an error well I
called you the weights not wait so I'll
go fix that okay this is driving okay so
and then this is what we get so let's
actually look at this so what we got is
the first iteration number of mistakes
was six and then we ended up actually at
the first iteration we ended up
converging to one two so then the second
iteration the number of mistakes just
became zero and then we just got one two
which is which is the weights that we
were hoping for
okay so that kind of looks okay to me
that's my training data everything looks
fine there's a question actually
I like integers
yeah so in this case you're sending all
the way time give it our update model as
well we're assuming that the number of
walks of the number of trams are
different where trim was in a different
location but the number of Lawson
appearances correct you would still
salute
I see what you're asking no you treat it
like it should figure figure that out so
um you we can go over an example after
after the class and I'll show you like
how how it actually doesn't all right so
okay so let's try 1 & 3 so we'd 1 & 3
takes a little bit longer and but it
does recover so 1 & 4 is actually the
interesting one because it does recover
something it does recover to 8
it doesn't recover 1 & 4 but like given
my data actually 2 8 is like like there
is no reason for me to get 1 1 & 4 like
the ratio of them is the thing that I
actually care about so even if I get 2 &
8 like like that is a reasonable set of
weights that one could get I'm gonna try
a couple more things so let's try one in
five so I'm gonna try one in five and
this is what I get
so I get the way to walk to be minus one
an afraid of charm to be one no more
mistakes is zero so why is this
happening
now your training is just all walking so
starting to just walk yeah so what's
happening here is if you look at my
training data up here my training data
is just has like walk like all walks it
hasn't seen tram ever so it has no idea
like what the cost of tram is with
respect to cost the walk so it's not
gonna learn that so we're gonna fix that
like one way to fix that is to go and
change the training data and actually
like get more data so we can kind of do
that so like just one thing to remember
is this is just going to fit your
training data whatever it is so yeah so
when we fix that then walk becomes - and
tram becomes nine which is not one and
five but it is getting there like it's a
better ratio and number of mistakes is
still zero so it really depends on what
you're looking for like if you're trying
to like match your data and know if your
number of mistakes is zero and you're
happy with this you can just go with
this and even though like it happened
like actually recovered the exact value
the ratios you can that's fine or maybe
you're looking for the exact ratios and
you should like run it longer more
iteration it's a question structured
perceptron like suspect - getting stuck
in local optima sorry I was looking at
that is a good question so actually let
me think about that
the Eustis and then i'll Pirie do you
actually know if this gets into local
optima i have experienced it personally
I feel like there's there's reasons for
it to do this it's doing this kind of me
think about this because even in a more
general form of it it's commonly used in
like like matching like sentence like
words and sentences so I haven't
experienced it either but I can look
into that and back to you house guys are
we just being at all of your optimal
pass
yes yeah yeah if we do figure out all
the alcohol paths and technically you
should just be complex right because I
can just match up and if you're feeding
it all the optimal path it should you
just matching path you're saying is yeah
so in terms of okay so yeah so in terms
of like bringing down the number of
mistakes then then it should always
match it but if you have some true like
weights that you're looking for and it's
not represented in your data set then
it's not necessarily like like learning
that so so in those settings they could
fall into local optima so kind of like a
another version of this is when you're
doing like reward learning and then you
actually have this true reward you want
to find like in those settings you can
totally fall into like local optima
because you want to find out what the
reward function is but you're right like
if you're just matching the data so the
scaling would be a different problem
right so the scaling is kind of yeah so
you can you have reward shaping so you
can have different versions of the
reverse function and if you get any of
them that is fine but but you might
still I get into local optima that's not
explained by reward shaping so okay so
that we can talk about these things are
fine maybe I should just move on to the
next topics cuz we have some more stuff
going on okay so I was actually going to
skip these slides because we have stuff
coming up but this is a more general
form of it so remember I was saying this
w is a function of a but you could you
could have a more general form where
your cost function is not just W as a
function of a
it is actually W times a set of features
and and then the cost of a path is W
times the features of the path and
that's just the sum of features over the
edges so so you can have this more
general form go over the slides later on
maybe because we got to move to the next
part but just real quick the update here
is this more general form up update
which is update your W based on
subtracting the features over your true
true path plus the features over your
predicted path so more general form of
this it's called Cohen's algorithm so
Mike Collins was working on this and in
natural language processing he was
actually interested in it in the setting
of part the speech target and tagging so
so you might have like a sentence and
you want to tag each one of the each one
of the labels here as a noun or verb or
determiner or now and again so so he was
thinking he was basically looking at
this problem as a search problem and he
was using like similar type of
algorithms to try to figure out like
like match what what the value like
match noun or like each one of these
parts of speech tags to the sentence so
he has some scores and then based on the
scores and and his data set he goes like
up and down he moves the scores up and
down which uses the same idea you can
use the same idea again in machine
translation so you can have like if you
have heard of like beam search you can
have multiple types like like a bunch of
translations of some phrase and then you
can operate and down rate them based on
your training data okay all right okay
so now let's move to a ice a ice a star
not a I star a star search alright
so okay so we've talked about this idea
of learning costs right so we've talked
about search problems in general doing
inference and then doing learning on top
of them and then now I want to talk a
little bit about kind of making things
faster using smarter ideas and smarter
heuristics there's a question
I would say what is the loss function
that we are trying to minimize this in
this structure so in this is this is a
prediction problem right so in that
prediction problem we are trying to
basically figure out what W WS are as
closely as possible as we are matching
these w wi prime to Y right so so
basically like the way we are solving
this is not necessarily as an
optimization the way that we have solve
other types of learning problems the way
we are solving it what is by just like
tweaking these weights to try to match
my Y as closely as possible to 2y time
okay all right okay so let's get taught
to talk about a star so I don't have
internet so I can't show these but I
think the link for these should work
when you go to their to the file so the
idea is if you go back to uniform cost
search like an uniform cost search what
we wanted to do was you want to get from
a point to some solution but we would
uniformly like increase explore the
states around us until we get to some
final state the idea of a a-star is to
basically do a uniform cost search but
do it a little bit smarter and move
towards the direction of the goal state
so if I have a goal state particularly
like in that corner maybe I can I can
move in that direction smarter right
okay so here is like an example of that
pictorially so I can start from a start
and and if I'm using uniform cost search
again I'm uniformly kind of exploring
all the states possible until I hit my s
end and then I'm happy I'm done I've
solved my search problem everything is
good but the thing is I've done all
these like wasted effort on this side
which is just not that great okay
so uniform cost search and in that sense
has this problem of just exploring a
bunch of states for no good reason and
what we want to do is we want to take
into account that we're just going from
a star to s and so we don't really like
need to do all of that we can actually
just try to get to the get to the end
state okay so so going back to maybe I'm
gonna go on this side so
going back to how these search problems
work the idea is to start from a start
and then get to some state s and then we
have this s end okay and what uniform
cost search does is it basically orders
the states based on past cost of s and
then explores everything around it based
on past cost of f s until it reaches s
end okay but when you're in state s like
there is also this thing called future
cost earnest right and ideally when I'm
on the state s I don't want to explore
other things on this side I actually
want to want to move in the direction of
kind of reducing my my future cost and
getting to my to my end State okay so so
the cost of me getting from s start to
us and it's really just like past cost
of s plus future cost of s and if I knew
what future cost of s was I would just
move in that direction but if I knew
what future cost of S is well the
problem was solved right like I had the
answers of my search problem like I'm
solving a problem so in reality I don't
have access to future costs sorry I have
no idea what future cost is but I do
have access to something like I can't
potentially have access to something
else and I'm gonna call that H of s and
that is an estimate of future costs so
I'm going to add a function called H of
s and this is called a heuristic and a
Serie C could estimate what future cost
is and if I have access to this
heuristic maybe I can update my cost to
be something as what the past cost is in
addition to that like I can add this
heuristic and that helps me to be a
little bit smarter when I'm running my
algorithm okay so so the idea is ideally
like what I would want to do is I want
to explore in the order of past cost
plus future cost I don't have future
costs if I had future costs I had the
answer to my search problem instead what
if star does is its it exports in the
order of past costs plus some H of s ok
so remember uniform cost search it
explores just in the order of past costs
so in uniform cost search like we don't
have that H of s okay
and H of s is a heuristic it's an
estimate of the future cost all right so
what does a star do it actually there's
something really simple so so a star
basically just does uniform cost search
so all it does is uniform cost search
with a new cost so before I had this
blue cost cost of SN a this was my cost
before now I'm going to update my cost
to be discussed prime of SN a which is
just cost plus the heuristic over the
successor of SN a minus the heuristic so
so that is the new cost and I can just
run uniform cost search on this new cost
so so I'm gonna call it cost prime
listener well what is that equal to that
is equal to cost of SN a which is what
we had before when we're doing uniform
cost search plus heuristic over
successor of SN a - heuristic over s so
why do I want this well what this is
saying is if I'm at in some state s ok
and there is some water state successor
of SN a so I can take an action a and
end up in successor of SN a and there is
some s end here that I'm really trying
to get to remember H was my estimate of
future cost what this is saying is my
estimate of future cost for getting from
successor to SN minus my estimate of
getting from future cost of s to us and
should be the thing I'm adding to my
cost function I should penalize that and
what this is really enforcing is it
basically makes me move in the direction
of s end because because if I end up in
some other state that is not in the
direction of s and then then that thing
that I'm adding here is basically going
to penalize that right it's going to be
saying well it's really bad that you're
you're going in that action I'm going to
put more costs on that so you never go
in that direction you should go in the
direction that go it's ghost towards
your s end and that all depends on like
what your H function is
and how good like of an H function you
have and how you're designing your your
heuristics but that's kind of the idea
behind it so here is an example actually
so let's say that we have this example
where we have ABCD and E and we have
cost of one on all of these edges and
what we want to do is you want to go
from C to e that's our plan okay so if
I'm running uniform cost search well
what would I do
I'm at C I'm going to explore B and D
because they have a cost of 1 and then
after that I'm going to explore a and E
and then finally I get to get to eat but
why did I spend all of that time we can
get a and B I shouldn't have done that
right like a and B are not in the
direction of getting to a cent so
instead what I can do is if someone
comes in tells me oh I have this
heuristic function you can evaluate it
on your state and this heuristic
function is going to give you four three
two and one and zero for each one of
these states then you can update your
cost and maybe you'll have a better way
of getting to a cent so this heuristic
in this case is actually perfect because
it's actually equal to future costs like
the point of the heuristic is to get as
close as possible to the future cost
this is exactly equal to future class
so with this heuristic what's going to
happen is my new cost is going to change
how is it going to change well it's
going to become the cost of whatever the
cost of the edge was before which was 1
plus h of the case of for example cost
of going from C to B if you work at C to
B it's the old cost which was 1 plus
heuristic at B which is 3 minus
heuristic at C which is 2 so that ends
up giving me 1 plus 3 minus 2 that is
equal to 2 and then similarly you can
compute like all these like new cost
values the purple values and and that
has a cost of 2 for going in this
direction and cost of 0 for going
towards E and if I just run uniform cost
search again here then I can get to like
much easier
there's a a sterling result in 3d
approaches where this opportunities like
go back with them better loss star
result in my greedy approaches like
where user greedy greedy
yes yeah so okay so so it's all so so
the question is is a star like causing
like greedy approaches so no actually we
were going to talk about that a little
bit a star dependent depends on the
heuristic you are choosing so depending
on the heuristic you are choosing a star
is actually going to be like return the
optimal value but yeah it does depend on
the heuristic so it actually does the
exact same thing as uniform cost search
if you choose a good heuristic what why
is cost of C C look really bad when it's
really not since to become so cost of CB
o because oh I see what you're saying
that's what we started with so this is
like the graph that I started with so I
started with the cost like the blue cost
being all one but now I'm saying those
costs are not good I'm going to update
them based on this heuristic so I can
get closer to the goal like as fast as
possible
and state well you returned like the
actual cause you wouldn't that's right
so so the question is what costs are you
going to return at the end and you do
want to return the actual cost so you
return the actual cost but you can run
your algorithm with this heuristic thing
added in because that allows you to
explore less things and just be more
efficient okay oh I got a move on
all right so okay so a good question to
ask is well what is this heuristic how
does this heuristic look like like can
any it does any heuristic like work well
so turns out that not every heuristic
works so here's an example so again the
blue things are the costs that are
already given these are the things that
I already have and I can just run my
search algorithm bit the red things are
the values of the heuristic someone gave
them to me for now in general we would
want to design them so someone comes in
and gives me this this heuristic values
and then what I want to do is I want to
compute the new cost values so the
question is is this heuristic good so I
get my new cost values they look like
this like does this work we don't have
time so I'm gonna answer that it's not
gonna work but the reason this is not
gonna work is though we just got a
negative edge there right so I'm running
uniform cost search at the end of the
day like a star is just uniform cost
search and I can't have negative edges
so I'm not like I'd like that it's just
not a good heuristic to have here so so
the heuristics need to have specific
properties and and we should you should
think about what those properties are so
one property that you would want to have
the heuristics to have is this idea of
consistency this is actually like the
most important property really so so we
talked about heuristics I'm going to
talk about properties of them here
heuristics H they should be consistent
so the consistent heuristic has two
conditions the first condition is it's
going to satisfy the triangle inequality
and and what that means is like the cost
that you're the updated cost that you
have should be it should be non-negative
so so this costs prime of this yesterday
this should be positive so
that means that the old cost of sna plus
h of successor i'm gonna use as prime
for that - H of S is greater or equal to
zero okay so that is the first condition
and then the second condition that we
are going to put is that future cost of
SN is going to be equal to zero right
because the future cost of the end state
should be zero so then the heuristic at
the end state is also equal to zero so
so these are kind of the properties that
we would want to have if you want to
talk about consistent heuristics okay
and they're kind of like natural things
that we would want to have right like
like the first one is basically saying
well the cost you are going to end up at
should be should be greater than or
equals 0 and you can run uniform cost
search on it but it's really like
talking about this triangle inequality
that we want to have right like we H of
s it's kind of an estimate of this
future cost so if I'm going to from s
take an action with that cost of s and a
dad added up H of successor of s SN a
should be greater than just H of s the
estimate of future cost of s so so
that's that's all it is saying and then
the last one also makes sense right like
I do want my future cost of s and to be
0 right so then the heuristic at s end
should also be equal to 0 because again
heuristic is just an estimate of the
future cost ok all right so so what do I
know about a star beyond that so one
thing that we know is that if if H is
consistent so if I have this consistency
property then I know that a star is
correct so that there's a theorem that
says a star is going to be correct if H
is consistent well we can kind of look
at that through an example so so let's
say that I am at the zero and I take a 1
and I end up at this one and I take a 2
and a minus 3 and 0 its to take a 3 so
let's say that I have I have kind of
like a path that looks like this okay so
then if I'm looking at the cost of each
each one of these right I'm looking at
cost of cost prime of 0 and a 1
well what is that equal to that's that's
my updated cost updated cost is old cost
which is cost of a 0 and a plus
heuristic value at s1 minus heuristic
value is 0 value this one point is
heuristic value I this year okay so so
that is the cost of going from s 0 and
taking a 1 I'm going to just write all
the costs for for the rest of this to
figure out what's the cost of the path
the cost of the path is just the sum of
these costs so s 1 a 2 is cost of s 1 a
2 plus heuristic is it as 2 - heuristic
it is 1 so that is the new cost of this
edge and the new cost of the last edge
which is cost prime of s 2 a 3 and that
is equal to the old cost stuff s 2 a 3
plus heuristic add s 3 minus heuristic
is ok so I just wrote up all these costs
if I'm talking about the cost of a path
then it's just that these costs added up
right so if I add up these costs what
happens a bunch of things get cancelled
out right
this guy gets cancelled up like this guy
this guy gets cancelled out right and
what I end up with is is some of these
new cost is cost Prime's of Si minus 1
AI is just equal to some of my old cost
of Si minus 1 AI plus my heuristic at
this last state is end State
- heuristic at this year
okay I'm saying my heuristic is a
consistent heuristic so what is a
property of a consistent heuristic the
heuristic value at s nth should be equal
to zero so this guy is also equal to
zero so what I end up with is is if I
look at a path with the new cost the sum
of the new cost is just equal to the sum
of the old cost minus sum sum constant
and this constant is just a heuristic
value at s 0 ok so so why is this
important because when we talk about the
correctness like remember we just proved
at the beginning of this lecture that
uniform cost search is correct so the
cost that it is returning is optimum
that is that if this cost a star is just
uniform cost search with a new cost so a
star is just running on this new cost
but this new cost is the same thing that
they have as old cost minus a constant
so if I'm optimizing the new cost it's
the same thing as optimizing the old
cost so it is going to return the
optimal solution okay all right so that
is basically the same things on the
slide like ok basically so that's one
property right so so we talked about
heuristics being consistent we have now
just talked about a star being correct
because it's uniform cost search it's
it's correct only if the heuristic is
consistent right like only if you have
that property because because that
consistency gets us gets us the fact
that this guy is equal to 0 and gets us
the fact that these guys are going to be
positive and I can run uniform cost
search on de um the next property that
we have here for for a store is a star
is actually more efficient than uniform
cost search and we kind of have already
seen this right like like the whole
point of a star is to not explore
everything and explore in a directed
manner so if you remember uniform cost
search like how does it explore well it
explores all the states that have a past
cost that are less than the past cost of
ascent so again remember the uniform
cost search you're exploring with the
with the order of path cost of states
and then we explore all those states
that
Haskell's less than the den state a star
like the thing that they have stored us
is it explores less states so it
explores states that have a past cost
less than past cost of the end state -
the heuristic so so if you kind of look
at the right side the right side just
became become smaller right like the
right side for uniform cost search was
just past cost of SN now it is past cost
of ascent - the heuristic so it just
became smaller and then why did it
become smaller because now I'm doing
this more directed search I'm not
searching everything uniformly around me
and and that's the whole point of the
heuristic okay and that makes it
actually more efficient so and then kind
of the interpretation of this is if H is
larger than then that's better right
like if my heuristic is as large as
possible well well that is better
because then I am kind of exploring a
smaller like area to get to the solution
the proof of this is like two lines so
I'm gonna escape that so let me actually
show how this looks like so if I'm
trying to get from a start to s and
again if I'm doing uniform cost search
I'm uniformly exploring so like all
states around me and that is equivalent
to assuming that the heuristic is equal
to zero like it's basically uniform cost
search is a star when the heuristic is
equal to zero so what is the point of
the heuristic the point of the heuristic
is to estimate what the future cost this
if I know what the future costs is then
then H of s is just equal to future cost
and then a and that would be awesome and
and I only need to like explore that
green kind of space and then the thing
I'm exploring is it's just the notes
that are under minimum past cough and
call cost path and I'm not exploring
anything extra right like that's the
most like efficient thing one can do in
practice like I don't have access to
future costs right and in practice if I
had access to future costs like the
problem was solved I have access to some
heuristic that is some estimate of the
future cost it's not as bad as uniform
cost search it's getting close to future
costs like look the value of future cost
and you're kind of somewhere in between
so it is going to be more efficient than
uniform cost search in some sense okay
all right so so basically the whole idea
of a star is it kind of distorts edge
edge cost and favor sees and States so
I'm going to add here that a star is
efficient so that is the other thing
okay all right so so these are all cool
properties one more property about here
is six and then after that we can talk
about your lack stations so so there's
also this other property called
admissibility
which is something that we have kind of
been talking about already right like
we've been talking about how this
heuristic
should get close to future cost and
should be an estimate of the future cost
so an admissible heuristic is a
heuristic where H of s is less than or
equal to future cost and then the cool
thing is if you already have consistency
then you have admissibility - so if you
already have this property then you have
admissibility - so another property is
admissible
which means H of s is less than or equal
to future cost of all right so the
proofs of these are again like just
one-liners so this one is more than one
line but it is actually quite easy it's
in the notes so you can use induction
here to prove to prove that if you have
consistency then you're going to have
admissibility - okay so so we've just
talked about how a star is the
sufficient thing you have talked about
how like we can come up with we haven't
talked about how you come up with your
six but we have talked about consistent
heuristics that are going to be useful
and they're going to give us
admissibility and they're going to give
us correctness and how like a star is
going to be this very efficient thing
but we actually have not talked about
how to come up with heuristics so let's
spend the next yeah couple of minutes
talking about talking about how to come
up with heuristics and then the main
idea here is just relax the problem just
relaxation so so what are so so the way
we come up with heuristics is we pick
the problem and just make it easier and
solve that easier problem so so that is
kind of the whole idea of it so remember
the HMS is supposed to be close to
future cost
and some of these problems can be really
difficult right so this so if you have a
lot of constraints and it becomes harder
to solve the problem so if you relax it
and we just remove the constraints we
are solving a much easier problem and
that could be used as a heuristic as a
value of heuristic that estimates what
the future cost this so so you want to
remove constraints and when we remove
constraints the cool thing that happens
is sometimes we have closed form
solutions sometimes you just have easier
search problems that we can solve and
sometimes you have like independence of
problems and we can find a solutions to
them and that gives us a good heuristic
so so that is my goal right like I would
want to find these heuristics so let me
just go through a couple of examples for
that so so let's say I have a search
problem and I want to get the triangle
to get to the circle and that is what I
want to do and I have all these like
walls there and that just seems really
difficult so what is a good heuristic
here I'm going to just relax the problem
I'm gonna remove like all those walls
just knock down the walls and have that
problem
that just seems much easier okay so so
well like now I actually have a closed
form solution for getting the triangle
get to the get to the circle I can just
compute them in half in this sense and I
can use that as a heuristic again it's
not going to be there like actually like
what future cost is but it is an
approximation for it so so usually you
can think of the heuristics as these
optimistic views of what the future
costs is like like it's an optimistic
view of the problem like what if there
was like no walls like if there are no
walls here then how would I get from
location to another location the
solution to that is going to give you
this future cost Val its estimate of
future cost value which is which is H of
s okay or the Tran problem let's say we
have the Tran problem but we have a more
difficult version of it where we have a
constraint and this constraint says you
can't have more tram actions than walk
actions so now this is my search problem
I need to solve this this seems kind of
difficult like we talked about how to
come up with States for it last time and
even that seems difficult like I need to
have the location I need to have the
difference between the walk and tram
that seems kind of difficult like like I
have an order of N squared states now so
instead of doing that well let me just
remove the constraint
I'm just gonna remove the constraint
relax it and then after relaxing it then
I have a much easier search problem I
need to deal with I only have this
location and then I can just go with
that location and everything will be
great okay all right so so the idea here
was like for this middle part is if I if
I remove these constraints I'm going to
have these easier search problems these
relaxations and I can compute the future
cost of these relaxations using my
favorite techniques like dynamic
programming or uniform cost search but
but the one thing to notice is I need to
compute that for one through n because
this heuristic is a function of state
right so I actually need to compute
future cost for this relaxed problem for
all states from 1 through n and that
allows me to have like a better estimate
of this there are some like engineering
things that you might need to do here so
so for example you might so here we are
looking for future cost so if you plan
to use uniform cost search for whatever
reason like maybe dynamic programming
doesn't work in this setting you need to
use uniform cost search you need to make
a few engineering things to make it work
because if you remember uniform cost
search would only work on past cost
doesn't work on future costs so you need
to like create a reverse problem where
you can actually compute future costs so
so a few engineering things but beyond
that it is basically just running our
search algorithms that we know on these
relaxed problems and that will give us a
heuristic value and we'll put that in
our problem and we'll go and solve it ok
and another cool thing that heuristics
give us is this idea of having
independent subproblems so so here's
another example I want to solve this
this eight puzzle and move blocks here
and there and come up with this new
configuration that seems hard again a
relaxation of that is just assume that
the tiles can overlap so the original
problem says the tiles cannot overlap
I'm just gonna relax it and say oh you
can just go wherever and you can overlap
ok so that is again much simpler and now
I have eight independent problems for
getting each one of these points from
one location to another location and I
have a closed form solution for that
because that's again
Manhattan distance so that gives me a
heuristic that that's an estimate that's
not perfect it's an estimate and I can
use that estimate in my original search
problem to solve the search problem so
here it was just some examples of this
idea of removing constant removing
constraints and coming up a bit better
heuristics so like knocking down walls
like why can't ramp freely overlapping
pieces and he says and that allows you
to kind of solve this new problem and
then the idea is you're reducing these
edge costs from infinity to some finite
finite cost okay all right so yeah so
I'm gonna wrap up here and I guess we're
going to talk about these last few
slides next time since you're running
wait but I think you guys have got like
the main idea so what's our next time